didn't you ever wonder where your mom
and dad learned hello
you're a wizard Harry
[Music]
your wizard Harry is probably one of the
most iconic phrases in the entire Harry
Potter franchise so in today's lesson
we'll revisit this iconic moment but
before we do that if this is your first
time joining us welcome each week we
create lessons like this one to help
English Learners like you understand
fast speaking natives without getting
lost without missing the jokes and
without needing subtitles so if you
haven't already done so be sure to smash
that like And subscribe button so you
never miss out on any of our new lessons
[Music]
almost 11 years have passed since
Dumbledore left Harry at the dursley
store so they could take care of him
until he would be old enough to start
his magical journey as we know the
jerseys were never that good to Harry
and his childhood was a tough one when
Harry is almost 11 his magical powers
start to show up until he starts talking
to a snake at the zoo can you hear me
it's just I've never talked to a snake
before
do you
oh wait
did you talk to people often
Harry then sets the snake free by making
the glass disappear without knowing
about his powers and this makes the
dursleys go mad but that was only the
start after that Harry starts receiving
some mysterious listens from Hogwarts
but the dursley's especially his uncle
Vernon do everything they can to stop
him from receiving the letters until we
have a very iconic moment when there is
an explosion that starts from the
fireplace
[Music]
and Uncle Vernon makes a very strange
decision
[Music]
and far they go to a Hut on the Rock in
the middle of the ocean and on Harry's
11th birthday he makes a wish that
changed his life from that moment on
make a wish Harry
sorry about that
it's Ruby is Hagrid coming to deliver
the news himself and to give Harry his
long-awaited letter but he also brought
something else for Harry got something
for you afraid I may have sat on it at
some point but I imagine it'll taste
fine just the same
ah
baked it myself words and all
thank you it's not every day your young
man turns 11 now is it hey
did you notice something quite funny in
the scene Hagrid said that he wrote the
phrase on the cake himself and we can
see that the words are spelled
incorrectly so instead of writing happy
and birthday ending in why he spelled
happy with double e at the end and
birthday with a e at the end this is one
of the reasons why this cake has become
so iconic for fans and then in the scene
after Hagrid started a fire with his own
pink umbrella Harry starts to ask him
some questions curious to know what all
that is about
excuse me
who are you rubius Hagrid keeper of keys
and grounds at Hogwarts
of course you'll know all about Hogwarts
sorry no
no
blow me Harry didn't you ever wonder
where your mum and dad learned oh
well
you're a wizard Harry
I'm a what a wizard and a thumping good
a night wager Harry seems confused and
he doesn't believe that he's a wizard
when Hagrid first says it
I can't be a wizard
I mean I'm just
Harry
just Harry
well just Harry
did you ever make anything happen
anything you couldn't explain when you
were angry or or scared
here Harry is probably remembering the
episode with the snake at this for
example when he made the glass disappear
then finally Harry receives his letter
from Hagrid and finds out that he is
expected at Hogwarts
Dear Mr Potter we are pleased to inform
you that you have been accepted at
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry you will not be clear we swore
when we took him in we'd put a stop to
all this rubbish you knew
you knew all along and you never told me
the jerseys don't want to let Harry go
to Hogwarts and they start an argument
with Harry
School of Witchcraft and Wizardry in the
world and he will be under the finest
Headmaster that Hogwarts has ever seen
Albus Dumbledore I will not pay to have
some crackpot old fool teaching magic
tricks
never
insult Albus Dumbledore in front of me
the end of the scene is hilarious now we
are ready to start learning all the
great vocabulary and pronunciation we
saw in these scenes
it's just I've never talked to a snake
before
so do you know the difference between
talk 2 and talk with talk to and talk
with can both mean carrying on a
conversation with one or more people for
example I enjoyed talking with my
friends about our future plans I enjoy
talking to my friends about our future
plans
however talk to often implies a
one-sided conversation such as between a
supervisor and an employee when one
person talks and the other just listens
check out this example say passing who's
that teacher talking to Professor
quarrel oh that's Professor Snape head
of Slytherin house
[Music]
me
he undeadly uses the question tag hasn't
he we can add question tags like isn't
it can you or didn't they to a statement
to make it into a question we often use
question tags when we expect the
listener to agree with our statement in
this case when the statement is
affirmative or positive we use a
negative question tag here's a great
example
Oculus repair room
that's better isn't it
however if the statement is negative we
use a positive question tag for example
this bag isn't yours is it
this means that the person does not
believe that the bag belongs to you
sorry about that
did you notice that Hagrid doesn't use
the pronoun I'm in the sentence well
when speaking or writing casually it is
common for native speakers to draw
pronouns like I and you the key is that
this only works in cases where it is
really obvious to your listener or
reader which person you're talking about
for example if a friend asked me what
are you doing later I could respond
going to the beach however if no one
asked the question and I simply said
going to the beach my friend might be
confused and ask who is going to the
beach got something for you afraid I may
have sat at it at some point but yeah
with Hagrid's accent he reduces
something to something then you is
pronounced as ya yeah this sounds like
something for you something for you also
the word afraid he said very fast so
what we hear is frayed
frayed
listen again
got something for you afraid I may have
sat at it at some point but I imagine
it'll taste fine just to say
we use the phrase just the same to mean
that despite what has been previously
mentioned nothing has changed so Hagrid
means that even though he might have sat
on the cake it will probably still taste
good here we could also use the phrase
in spite of which means the same thing
in spite of being back at Hogwarts I
feel more alone than ever
excuse
the phrase excuse me asking someone to
move so that you may pass to interrupt a
speaker to get someone's attention
asking someone to repeat what they have
just said
[Music]
all these are correct excuse me is used
as a polite apology in all these
different situations in the case of
Harry he doesn't know Hagrid and uses
this phrase to politely ask who he is
excuse me
who are you rubius Hagrid keeper of keys
and grounds at Hogwarts
hear the word grounds means land that
surrounds a building check out this
example it's nearly Nightfall
actually you realize I can't allow you
to go roaming The Ground by yourself
well then by all means come along sir
something else that's good to know is
that we call the person who takes care
of or maintains the grounds a groundsman
or a grounds keeper blow me Harry didn't
you ever wonder where your mum and dad
learned y'all so the word blimey is more
commonly used in British English and
it's a bit of an old-fashioned way of
expressing surprise excitement and alarm
it's a truly temperature Patronus chime
yes
I've seen it
why me Harry I didn't know you could do
that
a wizard something good tonight wager so
the word thumping is also more common in
the UK and is used to emphasize that
something is very great or important
therefore what Hagrid is saying is that
Harry is a great and important wizard
also if you have a really bad headache
you could say that you have a thumping
headache so if your goal is to become
something good at English then our real
life English app is just what you need
this is the only place where anytime
anywhere at the price of a button you
can connect with other English Learners
from around the world plus you'll have
access to real life conversations with
our podcast where we talk about how to
best learn English culture movies and so
much more the best part is that you can
practice with new transcripts and
flashcards every single week so what are
you waiting for download it right now
for free by clicking up here or down in
the description below or simply search
for real life English in your favorite
app store
a wizard and a thumping good a night
wager so the word wager means to risk
money on the unknown result of an event
or in the hope of winning money or some
other reward for example he tried to eat
an entire chocolate cake for a wager a
more common word for this would be to
bet on something
Dear Mr Potter we are pleased to inform
you that you have been accepted at
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry you will most likely find the
phrase we are pleased to inform you in
formal writing and speech such as
acceptance letters or official
announcements a casual way to say this
would be we are happy to let you know
here are some examples of how the word
please can be used in polite speech
pleased to know from now on you will be
following a carefully structured
Ministry approved course of defensive
Magic
carried
Potter
can't tell you how pleased I am to meet
you he's only the finest School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry in the world and
he will be under the finest Headmaster
that Hogwarts has ever seen how this
Dumbledore earlier in the scene we heard
Hagrid say that the cake would taste
fine in that context fine means
satisfactory or acceptable however here
finest or fine means excellent and of
great quality for example she purchased
the finest quality fabric for her
wedding gown
I will not pay to have some crackpot old
food teaching magic tricks so the word
crackpot can be offensive if you if you
describe someone all the ideas as
crackpot you disapprove of them because
you think that the ideas are strange and
crazy like tiger you really think that's
some crackpot scientist is going to make
me believe in sparkly Dames and
Vanishing men you just bought yourself a
one-way ticket back to the typing pool I
will not pay to have some crackpot old
food teaching magic tricks so in this
context a magic trick is a clever action
someone does that is intended to
entertain or deceive someone Harry's
Uncle Vernon hates magic so much that
instead of simply saying magic he says
magic tricks which makes it seem silly
deceitful and unimportant I don't see
the grimald that's because you're using
your eyes
clever Balthazar
always up to his little tricks
though that Hagrid really is one of the
most charismatic characters
Harry Potter universe and much of that
Charisma is owed to the actor who plays
Hagrid Robbie Coltrane who sadly as you
might know passed away recently as big
fans of the Harry Potter franchise we
here at the learn English with TV
channel would like to remember his
emotional message to all of his beloved
fans throughout the world as a tribute
cold rain finest gamekeeper in hogwart's
last day on Harry Potter
[Music]
the legacy of the movies is that my
children's generation will show them to
their children so you can be watching it
in 50 years time easy
I'll not be here sadly but
don't you think on it for one minute but
Hagrid will
yes
there's no Hogwarts Without You Hagrid
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
at some point but I imagine it'll taste
fine just the same
ah
I think to myself words and all
thank you it's not every day your young
man turns 11 now is it hey
Hagrid keeper of keys and grounds at
Hogwarts
of course you'll know all about Hogwarts
sorry no
no
blow me Harry didn't you ever wonder
where your mum and dad learned at all
what emotion does blimey Express here
happiness
fright
prize
[Music]
want more
you're a wizard Harry
I'm a what a wizard and a thumping good
a night wager this shows that Hagrid in
Harry
doubts
believes
agrees
[Music]
I can't be a wizard
I mean I'm just
Harry
just Harry
well just Harry
did you ever make anything happen
anything you couldn't explain when you
were angry or or scared
Dear Mr Potter
we are pleased to inform you that you
have been
an extra craft and
was it clear we swore and we took him in
we'd put a stop to all this rubbish you
knew
he knew all along and you never told me
he's one of the finest School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry in the world and
he will be under the finest Headmaster
that Hogwarts has ever seen how the
Dumbledore I will not pay to have some
crackpot old food teaching magic tricks
which of these has a similar meaning to
crackpot insane
ugly scary
thank you
never
insult Albus Dumbledore
in front of me
[Music]
if you enjoyed today's lesson then why
not test your English with Harry Potter
by checking out this lesson next these
tasks are designed to test you
in the most brutal way they're almost
cruel
[Music]
now don't worry because the tasks we
prepared for you today are not cruel but
super fun we've designed a quick test
for you to test your knowledge of
vocabulary and grammar in English and
the questions are based on all eight of
the Harry Potter movies plus you'll have
a fun and fun doing it are you ready